I remember when I first
saw the Radcliffe Gym.
It was on a really hot day.
In the summer before I
arrived as Radcliffe dean,
I'd been appointed
but I had not yet
moved to Cambridge
to take up the job.
And I was being given a tour
of the Radcliffe facilities.
And we climbed the stairs to
the old Radcliffe Gymnasium.
And it must have
been 105 degrees.
There's no air conditioning.
And it was the summer,
so it wasn't being used.
But there were stadium seating--
kind of temporary stadium
seating jammed into the room.
And I was told it was
being used for dance.
And it was so gorgeous-- the
bones beneath the stadium
seating and the
kind of disrepair
into which it had fallen.
The bones of the place
were just so glorious.
A huge space with
a balcony around it
that was meant to be a track
for the Radcliffe students
of the early 20th century.
And, as I understood it--
came to understand it--
the Radcliffe alums not only
used that balcony as a track,
they had to learn how
to lower themselves
on a rope from the balcony
onto the floor of the gymnasium
because it was believed
that it would be important
for women to know how to use
a rope to get out of a burning
building or some
other such challenge
that they might be faced with.
And I've talked to
numbers of Radcliffe alums
from a generation
before mine who
describe the terror
with which they
approached this requirement.
I vowed that I was going to try
to make that space new again
and to make it beautiful again.
And so it was renovated in the
first decade of this century.
And it now is the heart
of the Fellowship Program,
but also a space that is
used for public programs
and gatherings by the
Radcliffe Institute
and many other units
across Harvard.
It's a beautiful
space, and I think
has been restored to some of
the glories of its early design.
But you can see on the
wall some of the pictures
of young women undertaking
the kind of exercise that was
deemed appropriate for them.
I don't think I've ever
seen someone being--
or lowering herself on a rope.
I'm not sure there's any
photographic record of that.
But the space is
a wonderful one.
And I always feel
kind of heartened
when I go there
and think about how
the space is serving the
needs that are taking of the--
activities taking
place within it.